justement à la rencontre de l'un d'entre
eux dans notre rubrique qu'en pensent
les français témoignage poignant
d'olivier vite un enfer depuis plus de
trois ans gravement malades et
handicapés il vit dans un logement
insalubre près de nantes et pousse un
appel au secours
[Musique]
le gouvernement espère donc appliqué le
pass vaccinale dès la fin de semaine les
députés ont approuvé hier le projet de
loi renforçant les outils de gestion de
la crise sanitaire un texte doit
maintenant être examiné par le conseil
constitutionnel alors dans quel lieu le
pass vaccinale sera-t-il exigé qu'elle
exception on tente d'y voir plus clair
avec vous et el farj bonsoir hessel il
faudra donc bientôt justifier d'un
statut vaccinal pour notamment avoir
accès aux loisirs restaurants et bars
notamment
mais oui stéphanie toutes les personnes
âgées de 16 ans ou plus vont devoir donc
présenté un pass vaccinale pour avoir
accès à certains lieux ou le pass
sanitaires étaient obligatoires sont
concernés aient les bars les restaurants
mais aussi à les lieux de loisirs ou de
culture comme par exemple est les salles
de sport ou les musées l'accès aux
établissements de santé n'est en
revanche pas soumis aux passes vaccinale
mais reste conditionné au pass
sanitaires que nous connaissons noter
aussi que lé 12 15 ans restent eux aussi
soumis au passé ni terres actuelles et
staline y aura-t-il des contrôles et que
risque-t-on en cas de non respect des
règles
oui en cas de suspicion de fraude les
restaurateurs et cafetiers pourront par
exemple vérifier la concordance entre
l'identité de leurs clients et le pass
vaccinale il suivit suffira pour cela de
présenter un document officiel avec
photographie comme par exemple une carte
vitale ou encore un permis de conduire
en cas de fraude au pass vaccinale
sachets à stéphanie que les sanctions
ont été renforcées ainsi la détention
d'un pass vaccinale frauduleux pourrait
vous coûter à trois ans de prison et
45000 euros d'amendé
sauf si vous décidez de vous faire
vacciner dans les 30 jours après la date
de l'infraction merci est el farj pour
ces précisions et l'adoption du projet
de loi sur le pass vaccinale qui n'a pas
manqué de faire réagir la classe
politique soixante députés ont
d'ailleurs décidé de saisir le conseil
constitutionnel écouter
la république envers dont un a voté le
pen vaccinale ce dimanche 16 janvier
cette loi n'a rien de sanitaires nous ne
laisserons pas faire nous saisissons le
conseil constitutionnel et d avril 2022
nous abolirons les pêches le déshonneur
de l'assemblée nationale le crépuscule
de la france d'en haut hâte de sortir
des ténèbres
seulement 58 parlementaires à
l'assemblée nationale pour dire non à
cette folie du pass vaccinale il n'ya
point de plus cruel tyrannique celle que
l'on n'exerce à l'ombre des lois et avec
les couleurs de la justice montesquieu
ça y est le pass vaccinale et votez pour
six mois pour un an non permanents tout
le monde qui contrôle tout le monde
partout voilà l'idéal qui s'accomplit la
faillite de l'état de droit les libertés
aux abois
alors les libertés fondamentales sont
elles bafouent et avec ce projet de loi
sur le pass vaccinale sa mise en
application se fera t-elle dans la
douleur notamment dans les bars et
restaurants on attend toujours vos
réactions et n'est encore temps sur le
compte télégramme daté france et place à
notre des bars ce soir
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler ugo
bernalicis député est la fille du nord
avec nous en direct bonsoir ugo
bernalicis pente delvaux également sur
ce plateau coprésidents umih paris ile
de france vous représentez notamment les
restaurants et les cafetiers très
concernés on va en parler par cette loi
et enfin pierre tattevin chef du service
des maladies infectieuses du chu de
rennes merci à vous également alors le
passé n est acquis et sami vaccinale
pardon difficile un jeu à ne pas
confondre évidemment devrait entrer en
vigueur d'ici la fin de semaine si tout
va bien vous et restaurants les cafés
sont évidemment parmi les premiers
concernés à la fois parce qu'il faudra
se passe pour accéder à vos lieux et
aussi vous aurez on va en parler
évidemment un rôle de contrôle
renforcées comment tout d'abord
globalement vous accueillez cette
nouvelle loi franck des niveaux bas si
vous voulez pour nous si la double peine
parce qu'on parle des clients non parle
pas de notre personnel de nos équipes
puisqu'on va aussi devoir contrer nos
équipes puisque nos équipes seront aussi
soumis à ce nouveau pass vaccinale
aujourd'hui on n'avait pas on n'avait
pas l'autorité pour leur demander s'ils
avaient soit un test négatif ou s'il
était un schéma vaccinal complet je
rappelle que nous depuis le 1er
septembre on a déjà le passé ni terre
dans nos établissements là maintenant on
nous oblige le pass vaccinale plus les
pièces d'identité on en parlera sûrement
après il fait pour nous de toute façon
il est hors de question de contrôler les
pièces d'identité de nos clients on va
on va en parler dans ce qu évidemment
c'est ce qui a fait polémique ç'a failli
être retiré cette petite disposition et
finalement ça a été quand même adopté à
l'assemblée
ugo bernalicis vous vous êtes vent
debout parce que vous faites partie de
la france à moossou misez vous avez pris
l'initiative de saisir le conseil
constitutionnel vous avez d'ailleurs été
rejoint par des députés de tous bords
pas seulement à gauche d'ailleurs une
décision des sages est attendu jeudi
pour vous en quoi ce texte est encore
plus liberticide que le pass sanitaire
ne l'était déjà
écoutez c'est tout simplement parce
qu'il n'ya plus d'alternative par
rapport
au test pcr ou test antigénique et à la
vaccination dire que jusqu'à présent
vous pouviez ne pas être vaccinés ou ne
plus avoir votre schéma vaccinal complet
et avec un test pcr ou antigénique de
moins de 48 heures accéder au lieu de la
vie quotidienne et donc on voit bien que
la hausse est une forme de vaccination
obligatoire déguisé c'est ce qu'a dit
d'ailleurs olivier véran juste avant
l'examen en commission je crois qu'il
disait le 27 décembre pas de bêtises
juste après le dépôt du projet de loi
par le gouvernement devant le droit les
assemblées et ils s'étaient c'est un
problème fondamental parce que on va
mettre en place tout un tas de contrôles
alors que 90% des gens qui peuvent être
vaccinés le son est donc pour les dix
pas du fait des 10% en en vacciner on va
contrôler absolument 100 % de la
population et même par delà la question
c'est à la fin il m'a dit bon je suis
bien vu que l'objectif politique du
gouvernement c'est est de convaincre les
10% pardon de contraindre les 10%
restants et c'est bien là la difficulté
c'est que ça va convaincre personne de
leur tordre le bras l'inserm a fait une
étude 40 % d'entre eux c'est parce qu
ils sont éloignés du système de soins
c'est pas parce qu'il y aura le pass
vaccinale qui vont se rapprocher du
système de soins donc c'est bien pour le
problème de moyens et pour les 60 % qui
sont vraiment réfractaire au fait de se
vacciner en tant que tel ce n'est pas
alors qu'ils ne sont déjà en dehors des
clous avec le pass annie terre que
demain ils vont se dire ah bah oui c'est
bien sûr maintenant que c'est le pass
vaccinale je vais m'y mettre ce n'est
pas vrai la réalité c'est qu'ils vont
être marginalisés
socialement et économiquement alors même
que le gouvernement ne fait pas de
vaccination obligatoire tir qui est la
cohérence et vous avez le droit de ne
pas être vaccinés messi mais vous êtes
contre à la mort sociale et donc cette
incohérence profonde elle montre que ce
pass vaccinale en réalité n'est pas fait
pour lutter contre la pandémie il est
fait pour faire un coup politique pour
pour assécher les républicains et des
socialistes qui eux sont pour la
vaccination obligatoire et on a vu le
malaise de ces deux groupes respectifs
pendant leur pendant les débats et de la
difficulté pour eux deux de se
positionner et ça permet au gouvernement
de dire regardez on fait quelque chose
alors même qu'il n'y a toujours pas de
purificateurs d'air partout dans les
salles de classe dans le pays ça fait
deux ans qu'on le demande que les
masques ne sont pas gratuits qu'on n'a
toujours pas suffisamment de masques
ffp2 que les tests ne sont plus gratuit
pour tout le monde or le ts permet de
savoir si on porte ou pas le virus
concrètement on en est on n'a toujours
pas demandé la levée des brevets à
l'international pour pouvoir produire
massivement du vaccin pour nous mêmes et
surtout pour les autres pays à travers
le monde puisque sinon on s'expose à
nouveau à des vagues suivantes et donc
avec des doses supplémentaires de rappel
et c'est avec tout ce que ça implique
aussi comme difficulté d'invariants
alors de savoir si le vaccin est opérant
alors sur les formes graves on a bien
compris que ça fonctionne et c'est tant
mieux c'est pour ça qu'il faut se faire
vacciner mais notamment sur la
transmission qui est le coeur de la
sphère gabriela talent avait dit
lui-même il y a un an dans une interview
sur sur instagram on ne fera jamais de
vaccination obligatoire si le vaccin ne
protège pas contre la transmision
comprends mais pourquoi il ya plus de
logique à tout ça donc c'est tout un tas
d'éléments qu'il faut qu'il nous faut
dire que on est là dans une incohérence
de la part du gouvernement une fuite en
avant et de tout miser sur la
vaccination ça ne s'annonçait pas
d'ailleurs c'est le cas parce qu'on va
me redonner la parole on va vous
redonner la parole évidemment ugo
bernalicis mais on va pose évidemment la
question aux médecins aussi pierre
tattevin maladie des spécialistes pardon
spécialiste des maladies infectieuses
dans ce que nous a dit ugo bernalicis
voilà le vaccin il ne sert pas
nécessairement empêché de transmettre la
maladie est ce qu'un test négatif pierre
tattevin n'aurait pas été finalement
plus efficace qu'un vaccin justement qui
n'empêche pas d'être malade quand
quelqu'un pénètre dans un restaurant et
qu'il présente un test négatif au moins
on est sûr qu'il est pas mal à ce qui
n'est pas forcément le cas aujourd'hui
avec avec le vaccin donc lois
nécessaires selon vous
c'est quand même un constat d'échec
d'être obligés d'imposer ce pass
vaccinale alors qu'il ya des pays comme
l'espagne ou le portugal qui ont réussi
avec certainement une meilleure
communication meilleure pédagogie une
population qui était peut-être plus
prêts à avoir une très bonne couverture
vaccinale aussi bien pour elle les primo
vaccination pour les rappels donc en
tant que médecin je considère que c'est
un échec d'être arrivé à imposer d'abord
le pass sanitaires et ensuite le pass
vaccinale mais il faut comprendre que
c'est du point de vue médical je vais
parler juste du côté médical et du point
de vue de la santé publique
c'est beaucoup plus efficace de faire
des vaccinations à des populations que
de les tester à chaque fois qu'ils vont
dans un bar dans un cinéma d'abord parce
que le test il a sa valeur pendant les
quelques heures où on vient de le faire
et puis après des gens peuvent se
positive et le lendemain et ensuite
parce qu'il a quand même on peut pas
faire ça toutes les semaines tous les
trois jours et s'est dit que le vaccin
une fois que c'est bien fait on est
protégé alors sur les remarques de dire
qu'il protège pas de la transmission de
la contamination et c'est vrai qu'avec
le variant migrants il a perdu une bonne
partie de son efficacité antérieures
mais il est quand même et ça c'est
apparu on peut pas dire ça autrement ce
qui a probablement empêché notre système
hospitalier d'imploser à au moins deux
reprises une première fois au mois de
septembre une septembre quand ils et
d'épidémies terrible aux antilles qui
avait fait le choix de ne pas être bien
vacciné le choix collectif par rapport
aux autres départements français qui ça
s'est passé plutôt pas trop mal et vous
monde là de la dernière vague là qu'on a
eu la plus haute de delta en plein hiver
les endroits qui étaient pas le bien
bâti mais ça a été dramatique aussi il
vraiment je crois pas que de tester les
gens avant de rentrer dans les
restaurants doivent aller au cinéma
aurait permis d'éviter et tandis qu'une
couverture vaccinale tel qu'on l'avait à
90% a permis d'éviter la réalisation
l'hospitalisation de tony monde et on
voit bien j'ai foutu remporte la visite
ce matin dans le service les gens qui
font des formes drass et les gens qui
n'ont pas été vaccinés la grande grande
majorité des cas donc c'est à la fois
pour les protéger eux et pour protéger
le système de santé pour qu'on puisse
s'occuper des autres personnes on est
obligé de mettre en place des règles qui
font qu'on a une bonne couverture
vaccinale honnêtement je pense pas que
c'était une bonne chose d'aller
jusqu'aux passe vaccinal à une partie de
ce qui vient d'être dit sans doute
presse va pas faire gagner énormément
mais le bassin sanitaire de l'été
dernier nous a permis de passer de 60
tours 190 places sans couverture
vaccinale et nous a très bien protégé
sur les cibles alors fondettes vous on
l'a dit on vous demande voilà beaucoup
de choses les restaurateurs déjà à vos
salariés à vos clients il ya cette
notion de contrôle on a commencé à en
parler ça évidemment ça s'appelait pas
au président de l'union des métiers des
industries de l'hôtellerie et
restauration on va lui donner la parole
avant de vous écouter
le contrôle d'identité ne sera pas
appliquée car 1 il n'est pas obligatoire
et deuxièmement on n'est pas formé à
juger de la validité de ce pass mais
aussi parce qu'on n'a pas le temps et on
a déjà suffisamment de problèmes dans la
restauration aujourd'hui franck delvaux
votre réaction c'est vrai que là on vous
demande d'outrepasser votre rôle de
restaurateurs quand même oui vous savez
vous savez j'ai l'habitude de dire que
nous on est là pour mijoter le boeuf
bourguignon pour que les gens puissent
venir se restaurer et les policiers et
gendarmes eux sont là pour contrôler les
pièces d'identité nous c'est pas notre
métier il faut une formation on n'est
pas policier gendarme du jour au
lendemain donc nous on peut pas du jour
au lendemain contre les pièces
d'identité et quand on me dit oui mais
pour les chèques vous demandez pièce
d'identité je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui il ya plus un restaurant
qui prend les chèques donc non on ne
demande pas une pièce d'identité et on
ne le fera pas parce que c'est pas notre
métier et ça peut conduire à des
événements graves pourquoi demander la
pièce de théâtre telle personne est
passée la question sur qu'elle traitera
l'eau a dit en cas de doute c'est bien
ça en k2 dans mon cas j'ai tout jeté le
doute sur quoi sur quoi est basée le dos
ça peut être un délit de faciès dont il
peut y avoir des gros problèmes et peut
y avoir des accidents graves de
personnes qui vont s'énerver vers le
restaurateur donc on le fera pas c'est
pas notre métier on est déjà dans une
difficulté économique très important
depuis lé du mois de janvier à cause du
télétravail le distance y aller tu sais
c'est pas pour encore en plus contre les
pièces d'identité donc non d'ailleurs on
va voir le premier message télégramme un
semis danic un ma fille travaille dans
la restauration rapide elle subit de
fréquents contrôles de police elle
travaille la boule au ventre et elle est
la limite du burn out ugo bernalicis est
vrai que les restaurateurs ils ont quand
même pas signé pour ça ça paraît insensé
cette notion de doute sur quoi sur qui
comment peuvent agir les restaurateurs
dans ce domaine du contrôle on leur fait
peser beaucoup de chance sur les épaules
oui bien sûr c'est une des dix prix ce
que nous contestons et que nous
contesterons devant le conseil
constitutionnel j'espère qu'on obtiendra
la censure au moins sur ces dispositions
là les sénateurs eux aussi avaient été
très clair il avait refusé dans la très
grande majorité je crois que le vote n'a
été même à l'unanimité en séance en
première lecture pour pour refuser ces
contrôles parce qu'ils n'apportent rien
et finalement on voit bien comment on
bureaucratise cette gestion de la
pandémie on rajoute se passe vaccinale
on se rend compte qu'il ya des gens qui
fraudent et donc il faut bien les
contrôler mais s'il n'y avait pas eu de
passe pas de passe pas de fraude donc on
voit bien comment on dépense énormément
d'énergie pourquoi normalement en
théorie c'est pour que les gens vaccinés
c'est ça le but recherché on est déjà à
91% des personnes qui ont un schéma
vaccinal complet 93 je crois qu'on
entamait déjà une première dose donc
l'objectif pour ceux qui ne sont pas
encore convaincus c'est d'aller les
convaincre encore une fois est ce qu'on
va en leur tendant le bras faire mieux
non on va juste les mettre à l'écart
encore plus et davantage bon donc on en
revient à ce que disait l'organisation
mondiale de la santé et ce qui était dit
en préambule sur notamment l'espagne par
exemple qui a tout misé sur des grosses
campagnes pour convaincre les gens et ce
qui fait que d'ailleurs ils les gens là
bas sont moins réfractaires à faire la
dose suivante et ne le font pas avec le
pistolet sur la tempe ils le font parce
qu'il pense que c'est utile de le faire
parce que ça réduit les formes graves
pour aider l'hôpital qui est surchargé
pour des bonnes raisons et parrainé moi
de vous couper aussi mais je me dois de
vous le dire aussi dans certains pays
comme l'italie d'ailleurs ce qu'ils
appellent le sioux par une passe elle ne
pose pas plus de problèmes que ça il ya
d'ailleurs une vaccination obligatoire
pour les plus de 50 ans est aussi se
passe vaccinale d'autres pays d'europe
également pourquoi en france est aussi
compliqué dans les mentalités peut-être
ce n'est pas une question de mentalité
je crois pas je veux pas
allez sur ce champ là parce que ça nous
on irait vers des caricatures qui ne
sont qui ne sont pas réalistes qui ne
sont pas vraies je pense qu'il ya un
sujet sur la gestion de crise et sur la
parole publique en tant que tel et qu'en
france où il la parole publique a été
beaucoup égratigné par des mensonges à
répétition des caricatures à répétition
sur le pass sanitaire par exemple en
juillet dernier j'étais dans l'hémicycle
et on leur disait déjà d'être sur la
ligne de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé convaincre plutôt que contraindre
et ça les pousser à des caricatures le
ministre vérone le disait oui mais si
nous sommes tous faits qu signer ces
bons l'épidémie sera derrière nous on en
aura terminé
à une sorte de professeur tournesol qui
arrivent là et qui nous explique que ça
de manière très docte alors qu'on avait
déjà les chiffres à l'époque du du
conseil scientifique qui me disait que
pour le variant delta la protection
contre la transmission était de 50% et
que la protection contre les formes
c'est symptomatique qui amène et qui
peuvent les hospitalisations qui amène à
l'hôpital c'était environ 80 % ça laisse
quand même 20% restants qu'il faudra
prendre en charge en fait quand donc le
hic c'est qu'on a aujourd'hui en charge
il ya des vacciner les gens qui sont
pris en charge à l'hôpital et donc on
leur avait dit mais attendez il faut
quand même pas qu'on rouvre tout en
grand il faut pas qu'on puisse se
retrouver parce qu on est vacciné c'est
bon on peut ce qu'on peut retirer le
masque se serrer dans les bras se faire
des bisous etc or c'était la
contrepartie on voit bien comment ils
ont géré ça de manière tout à fait
politiciens en maniant la carotte et le
bâton et quand quand on leur a exposé
tout ça il en avait rien à faire la
preuve qui s'est fait contaminée après
le congrès des maires en pleine vague
delta y avait pas encore au micron c'est
le premier ministre jean castex parce
que voilà ça serrait des mains il n'y
avait pas de masque parce que tout le
monde était censé avoir le passage du
ter à ce moment là donc je crois qu'il
est nécessaire de se dire que peut-être
qu'en italie ils ont été clairs sur la
vaccination obligatoire ken parole
publique qui a pas été décrédibilisés
qu'ils ont pas expliqué que les masses
ça servait à rien qu'ils n'ont pas
expliqué que si vous étiez à l'école
contaminés ben les élèves l'été mais
l'enseignant n'était pas qu'à contacter
ce qui est encore le cas dans les
protocoles aujourd'hui à l'école ou que
si un enseignant est positif les élèves
sont pas considérés comme cas contact
des choses complètement dingue
la nôtre histoire de assis debout
alors j'ai bien compris en plus que
c'était pour limiter la jauge aux seules
places assises j'ai bien compris mais ça
n'a même pas été présenté comme ça ça
n'a même pas été présenté lors de la
parution pierre tattevin vous en tant
que médecin justement il ya une
ambivalence vous vous réjouissez de ces
mesures qui sont certes sévère on a
entendu que vous auriez voulu que ça se
passe autrement être plutôt dans la dans
la conviction que dans l'imposition mais
tout de même
voilà on imagine que vous êtes partagés
parce que vous n'avez pas envie de voir
arriver les gens et l'immersion quelle
est votre opinion est ce que on en a
trop fait justement et on n'a pas su
convaincre à l'instar peut-être d'autres
pays
ouais je pense qu'il on peut pas être
trop critique sur ce qui s'est passé
l'été dernier en avait ça fait six mois
qu'on avait le vaccin en libre accès
gratuit que tout le monde pouvait la
voir et on arrivait à peine on est
arrivé au maximum des gens qui est qui
était volontaire d'emblée pour le faire
on était à 60% pression n'était resté là
on peut déjà prédire qui ont eu des
catastrophes
à la rentrée la
rondelle tu as commencé à circuler on
aurait probablement dû fermer des écoles
fermées les restaurants etc les pays qui
avaient pas qui était pas bien vaccinés
à ce moment là c'est ce qu'ils ont fait
donc il faut pas regretter et l'autre
chose c'est que l'on peut pas dire non
plus on a tout de suite imposé se passe
sanitaire ça a été fait au mois de
juillet six mois après de la
distribution des vaccins et cette partie
là était plutôt bien géré et honnêtement
quand on emballe entre collègues et sans
aucune couleur politique de rien du tout
si on se dit où est ce qu'on aurait bien
aimé passer ces deux ans de crise
sanitaire la banque était peut-être
qu'après la première vague et une
majorité de gens corps et du rebond en
allemagne il vaut mieux gérer puis un an
plus tard finalement l'allemagne
s'étaient pas le modèle et finalement la
france a pas fait pire qu'ailleurs donc
on peux pas faut pas critiquer faut pas
dire que que c'est la gestion
calamiteuse de la crise sanitaire qui
fait quand on est tous les pays d'europe
ont souffert et certains beaucoup plus
que nous donc on ne part pas du tout
dire que tout était mal même quand on
est dans de la couleur politique d'en
face que je suis tout à fait d'accord
parmi les choses qui ont été dites
premièrement ça a été beaucoup mieux si
on avait pu expliquer les choses oh pour
vous c'est bon c'est mieux d'être
vaccinés comme on réussit à faire
l'espagne portugal donc ça c'est un
constat d'échec et deuxièmement là aussi
je peux reconnaître je ne suis pas non
plus persuadés de passer un sommet
depuis 15 jours là on voit bien avec la
fameuse phrase de ma conquête le pass
vaccinale je suis pas du tout sûr que du
point de vue santé publique du point de
vue sanitaire c'est soit enfin en
attaque j'ai pas de couleur politique là
dessus mais mon avis de médecin c'est
qu'on a plutôt pas mal fait jusqu'à ya
pas très longtemps et que ce qui se
passe ce mois ci est quand même beaucoup
moins santé publique on va vous redonner
la parole aux hommes et anaïs hills
parce que je sens que voulait répondre à
pierre tattevin mais il ya aussi font
d'elle vaut à notre ami en plateau
d'abord je voudrais vous montrez ccm en
vain pour les entreprises et les clients
parce que cette loi et est assorti aussi
du bâton un client qui détient faut
passer trois ans d'emprisonnement et
45000 euros damende même si sa baisse un
peu c'est quand même conséquent une
entreprise qui ne vérifient pas le passé
l'identité 1000 euros damende les
entreprises qui ne pratiquent pas le
télétravail à 1 500 euros par salarié
dans une limite de 50 mille euros
vous avez appliqué tous la fringale vous
vous nous avez déjà dit que vous ne
feriez pas les contrôler mais enfin
demandé aussi son passé ni terre un
salarié est ce que ça ne pose pas un
petit peu la question du secret médical
on imagine le cast aip dans les acp dans
les directions des ressources humaines
alors nous on le fait depuis le 1er
septembre d'ailleurs on peut être étonné
que quand le premier ministre a demandé
à le faire dans l'ensemble des
entreprises en 48 heures sa petite chute
alors que chez nous depuis le 1er
septembre je le redis on le sait pas
assez on demande le pass sanitaires à
nos employés toutes nos équipes pour le
pas salutaire on demande à nos clients
le pass sanitaire également depuis le
1er septembre donc on voit bien que nous
on est la variable d'ajustement de ce
gouvernement chaque depuis mars 2020
chaque fois que ça va pas c'est les bars
les restaurants les discothèques les
hôtels discothèques 1 il existe son père
mais c'est fermé je peux vous l'être
dans les hôtels aujourd'hui à que
distants ciel il ya plus personne dans
les restaurants on est à -30 -40 % et on
n'a pas d' aide parce que on a un
ministre de l'économie qui est sourd il
veut pas nous écouter il veut nous aider
des mois 50 % à -50 % une entreprise
elle pense à déposer le bilan elle pense
plus aux aides donc nous et j'en profite
pour leur dire on demande l'aide profite
et - 30 % de chiffre d'affaires cevital
sinon on aura des dépôts de bilan aux
masses dans les hôtels les restaurants
et les bars dans les mois à venir ugo
bernalicis justement sur le fait qu'une
entreprise de vendre le pass
vaccinale un salarié un certificat de
vaccins votre sentiment c'est vrai que
là on autre passe peut-être il ya la
question du secret médical et qui met
peut-être les entreprises dans
l'embarras
bah écoute et déjà je n'étais pas
tellement favorable à la vaccination
obligatoire y compris pour les soignants
dans un premier temps parce que je
pensais qu'il fallait se donner le temps
de continuer à convaincre plutôt que de
contraindre et on a vu comment la
situation était extrêmement critique
dans les outre mer s'était rappelé tout
à l'heure et on en est pas vraiment
sorti et qu'on a radicalisé des gens qui
pouvaient potentiellement utiles et de
bonne volonté pour pour la suite ça
c'est le premier point et derrière je
suis intervenu moi même à plusieurs
reprises dans l'hémicycle en exemple
attendez vous dites que le pass
vaccinale ne s'appliquera pas aux
salariés du privé or ça vient d'être dit
on le savait si votre si vous êtes un
établissement recevant du public ou
votre public doit avoir un pass vacciner
alors vos salariés doivent aussi la voir
ce qui devient c'est qui revient à ce
qu'il y ait une vaccination obligatoire
en dehors des soignants autant pour les
soignants même en y étant posé on
pouvait le comprendre on est dans le
milieu médical les soignants ont des
noms sont déjà astreints à d'autres
types de vaccination obligatoire par
rapport au public la population générale
il y avait une logique on va dire avec
qui se défend là je vois pas je vois pas
la logique c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
mettre un tour de bras supplémentaires
effectivement une entorse au secret
médical et si vous me le permettez je
vais revenir sur ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure en disant on avec 60% de la
population qui était vacciné au mois à
l'été avant le passé ni terre c'est
factuellement vrai un pourcentage de
personnes vaccinées pourquoi on en était
là moi je voudrais pas qu'on soit
amnésique sur un certain nombre de
choses pendant trois mois c'était la
galère pour trouver des doses pour les
gens qu'ils voulaient c'était la galère
il ya déjà des rendez vous qui était
déprogrammé les vaccinodromes c'était
bien dans les grandes villes mais vous
sortiez des grandes villes c'est bon
c'était le désert c'était la chasse aux
doses et vous avez qu un certain type de
doses est pas tout vous pouviez pas
avoir le libre choix de votre vaccin
comme c'était pourtant précisé pro
proposée dans la stratégie de l' oms
notamment sur convaincre plutôt que que
contraindre et quand quand quand est ce
que les gens se sont fait vacciner ils
se sont pas fait vacciner quand le pass
sanitaire est entrée en vigueur
ils se sont fait vacciner quand emmanuel
macron à parler à la télé et moi je
crois que je crois que la parole d'un
président de la république qui vient à
la télé expliquer la situation et dire
attendez là il faut vraiment vous
vacciner sans pour autant imposer le
pass en lisant vos libertés sont
restreintes et c'est derrière peut avoir
un effet pro actives sur le sujet et
dernier élément quand on était en juin
et qui commençait à y avoir une
décélération des gens qui se mettaient à
se vacciner c'est aussi pour une autre
raison objective c'est que vous deviez
faire les deux doses au même endroit et
à un mois d'intervalle pour avoir votre
schéma vaccinal complet ça a été réduit
à près à trois semaines d'ailleurs mais
d'abord c'était un mois or qu'est ce qui
se passe en juin pour pas mal de gens
n'a pas la majorité des français mais
malheureusement mais c'est que vous
commencez à penser aux vacances à
juillet à août et si vous pouvez pas
vous faire votre même dose au même
endroit eh bien vous vous dites je vais
le faire en septembre à la rentrée
girier une saisonnalité aussi de
l'activité des gens c'est les vacances
on verra plus tard et qu'est ce qu'ils
ont fait en même temps qu'ils ont mis en
place le pass sanitaires ils ont
débloqué le fait qu'on puisse faire sa
deuxième dose n'importe où dans le pays
ce qui aurait déjà dû être le cas dès le
départ voilà on a mis des contraintes à
un moment donné qu'on a levé au fur et à
mesure je crois que c'était beaucoup
plus efficace et que je crois énormément
la logistique dans ce pays qui a été je
vous le dis dans les premiers temps des
retards à l'allumage est à la ramasse
par rapport à l'espagne et les
stratégies d'aller vers d'aller vacciner
dans les ehpad et c'est en retard par
rapport à l'espagne on a on a on a été
en retard d'une vague sur ce qui est de
la vaccination et je crois que ça à
décridibiliser aussi énormément là les
pouvoirs publics et leur capacité à
convaincre carte advint je voulais juste
pour rectifier à deux choses fausses qui
viennent d'être dire même si je suis pas
globalement opposés à tout ce que vous
racontez mais d'abord depuis le début a
droit de se vacciner dans deux endroits
différents il ya une plateforme
nationale moi même j'ai fait mes deux
premiers vaccins endroits différents
et donc la deuxième chose qui paraît
s'était passé parce qu'ont récemment
elle vous a laissé parler
c'est tout à fait faux on pouvait aller
dans n'importe quel centre on prenait
rendez vous on a vacciné jusqu'en
février à l'hôpital parce que les
centres étaient pas fonctionner à partir
de mars les centres ouverts en ville et
tous nos patients et je fais médecin je
vous laisse parler quand vous êtes
politiciens de machines médecin mes
patients aux faveurs de m dos où il
voulait la faire depuis depuis le
printemps donc ça c'est pas vrai ce que
vous avez dit et l'autre chose qui est
pas vrai crois pas l'effet magique de
monsieur mâcon qui vient pour vaincre
les gens à la télé on était en plateau
depuis un mois on avait atteint ce qu'on
appelle le plafond de verre c'est à dire
on avait fini de vacciner tous les gens
qui étaient vraiment volontaire et
malheureusement est encore une fois mais
je défends tapas vaccinale je pense pas
que c'était une bonne idée mais le passé
sanitaires à l'été dernier ça a boosté
complètement et alors je crois que vous
prêtez vraiment trop de magie à la voix
de emmanuel macron parce que je pense
pas que c'est parce qu'ils sont et font
passer à la télé pour dire vaccinez vous
sais pas ce qu'il a dit désormais vous
irez pas dans les restos vous y répond
de six loges désirait pas en discothèque
si vous n'avez pas le passé honnêtement
on va faire le mot de la fin pour vous
franck delvaux avec ce sondage un riche
en enseignements 58% des français
favorables aux pass vaccinale à skis
français sur 10 5 points de moins que le
dernier sondage début janvier 6 français
sur 10 également pour la vaccination
obligatoire des des 18 ans ça vous
inspire quoi ces chiffres parce que même
si c'est un chiffre qui est en baisse
c'est un sondage qui est paru samedi
pour le jdd un sondage ifop les français
sont quand même assez docile six
français sur dix ans en faveur de voile
à 2 to b to c passe
bien sûr mais nous on contrôle le pass
anita ont le contrôle moi chaque fois il
faisant d'un établissement on ne
demandait pas sanitaires et on va
demander le pass vaccinale là on n'est
pas d'accord c'est de voir contrôler
pièce d'identité il existe plein de faux
pas ce qui circule croit plus de 180 m
haies sanou d'enquêté non c'est à l'état
d'enquêter c'est l'état d'enquêter sur
ces filières qui vendent des faux-pas
sanitaires qui sont scandaleux mais
c'est pas à nous de faire chacun son
métier nous on est là pour faire mijoter
le boeuf bourguignon pas pour contrer
les pièces d'identité mais et contrôlera
les passes les irlandais les photos
n'est ce pas certains d'entre vous on
est tout simplement une faute dont on a
dit oui beaucoup on a passé comme sur la
carte de d'insécurité sociale où on a
notre photo ça aurait pu être une
solution si mais une fois de plus je le
redis on ne vous qu'on demandera pas les
pièces d'identité à nos clients et on
contrôlera le pass vaccinale comme on a
contrôlé le pass sanitaire avant merci
en tout cas tous les trois font d'elle
vocaux bernalicis e pierre tattevin
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france et tous
toujours dans la lutte contre le coc
vide tous sportifs professionnels venant
de l'étranger devraient être vaccinés
pour concourir en france une précision
du gouvernement français ce matin au
lendemain de la sphère djokovic et de
l'expulsion d'australie du numéro un
mondial de tennis thibault janin pour
les détails
le rêve d'un 10e titre à melbourne s'est
envolé pour novak djokovic
expulsé du sol australien dimanche soir
le numéro un mondial de tennis a atterri
ce lundi à dubaï ce départ les pilotes
d'un bras de fer judiciaire entre le
serbe de 34 ans et le gouvernement
australien à belgrade où djokovic est
considéré comme un héros les autorités
crie au scandale
c'est une décision scandaleuse
je suis déçu elle a montré comment
fonctionne l'état de droit dans certains
autres pays ou comment il ne fonctionne
pas
j'ai hâte de voir novak djokovic dans
son pays en serbie que nous traversions
tout cela ensemble et que nous le
soutenions dans ces moments difficiles
un soutien affiché en plein coeur de la
capitale serbe en témoigne ce message
d'encouragement sur lequel on peut lire
nos les tuer la fierté de la serbie de
son côté le gouvernement australien qui
s'est félicité de la décision d'expulser
novak djokovic tente de rassurer quant à
la sauvegarde des relations
diplomatiques entre les deux pays
je suis absolument convaincu que les
relations bilatérales très positive
entre l'australie et la serbie se
poursuivront sur la base solide dont
elle bénéficie actuellement je suis
également absolument certaine que la
dynamique diaspora australe au serbe qui
joue un rôle si important dans notre
communauté continuera également à le
faire et je suis impatiente de
travailler avec mes homologues et avec
les membres du gouvernement serbe y
compris le chargé d'affaires ici en
australie en ce moment pour veiller à ce
que ce soit le cas
de quoi laisser penser que la sphère
pourrait connaître en quelques
rebondissements en attendant une chose
est certaine l'open d'australie a débuté
sans le numéro un mondial reste
désormais à savoir qui succèdera à novak
djokovic au palmarès des vainqueurs
réponse dans deux semaines et la chine
elle se prépare à accueillir les jeux
olympiques d'hiver dans un contexte de
crise par contre sanitaire
particulièrement inquiétant dans le pays
depuis mars 2020 le nombre de quatre
kobe n'a jamais été aussi élevées
notamment avec l'apparition en 2003
conséquence le comité d'organisation des
jo a déjà annulé aujourd'hui la vente de
tickets au grand public malgré tout
certains spectateurs seront sélectionnés
pour assister à l'événement enfin via
des milliers de tests ou encore les
bulles sanitaire pékin met tout en
oeuvre pour endiguer l'épidémie hélène
masse cueillir
mauvais timing pour la chine tandis que
les jeux olympiques d'hiver s'ouvrent
dans moins de trois semaines l'arrivée
de mikron seule la larme le pays qui
était parvenu à enrayer la circulation
du virus pendant deux ans fait face à
une reprise de l'épidémie avec ce
premier cas du variant officiellement
détecté dans la capitale ce samedi
quelqu'un est entré dans la période des
jeux olympiques d'hiver et doit faire
face à la double pression de la
prévention de l'importation de cas
étrangers et de la résurgence d
infection locale
aujourd'hui un nouveau cas local
confirmé à sonner l'alarmé pour notre
travail de prévention et de contrôle les
départements à tous les niveaux doivent
maintenir un état d'urgence et renforcer
la prévention et le contrôle de façon
conjointe tianjin à niang shanghai ou
zhuhai la liste des foyers épidémiques
dans le pays s'allonge de jour en jour
les autorités qui restent fidèles à leur
stratégie zéro qu'ovide déploie des
mesures rapides mais coercitives
fermeture des écoles confinement
immédiat et dépistage systématique de
toute la population
dès l'apparition des premiers cas la
ville la plus touchée par la résurgence
du virus si yann connaît une accalmie au
terme de trois semaines de confinement
strict de ses 13 millions d'amis
comme la situation épidémique s'améliore
nous allons accélérer la levée des
mesures de confinement dans certaines
zones et complexe résidentiel en partant
du principe qu'il n'y a pas de reprise
de l'épidémie pour les autres zones ne
remplissant pas les conditions de levée
du confinement nous continuerons à
adopter des mesures strictes
une olympiade qui s'annonce au haute
surveillance les délégations commencent
à arriver pékin compte sur la mise en
place d'une bulle olympique étanche une
enclave sanitaires prévues pour
accueillir les athlètes journalistes et
officiels venus du monde entier avec un
contrôle strict les sportifs seront
testés toutes les six heures sans aucun
contact possible avec la population les
autorités elles se disent confiantes
c'est sous contrôle donc nous nous
accrochons à toutes les mesures que nous
avons mises en place et nous sommes
confiant qu'elles seront suffisantes si
la situation ne s'aggrave pas
spectaculairement pas d'annulations de
dernière minute à l'ordre du jour en
attendant les regards restent tournés
vers la chine avec cette nouvelle
épreuve test pour sa stratégie zéro co
vide
et la recrudescence des quatre co vide
inquiète également en tunisie les
fédérations de l'enseignement secondaire
appelle les autorités à prendre de
nouvelles mesures elles demandent entre
autres la suspension des cours pour une
période déterminée
objectif réduire les risques de
contamination
les explications de notre correspondant
baisse m shelly à tunis alors que le
pays avait connu une accalmie après
l'été meurtrier le variant omicron s'est
propagée ces dernières semaines à une
vitesse inquiétante avec un taux de
positivité dépassant les 30 % le
ministère de la santé a annoncé six
nouveaux décès et près de 10 mille
nouvelles contaminations abdelraouf
yakari secrétaire général adjoint de la
fédération nationale de l'enseignement
secondaire tire la sonnette d'alarmé
demande aux autorités de réagir
rapidement pour freiner le taux de
contamination dans les écoles écouter la
situation sanitaire dans les
établissements scolaires est devenue
très dangereuse
le nombre de contaminations par le virus
en milieu scolaire est repartie à la
hausse alors que 70 % des élèves refuse
de rejoindre les bancs de l'école pas
peur de contamination nous demandons au
président de la république à la chef du
gouvernement najlae bouden au ministre
de l'éducation et au comité scientifique
de suspendre les cours pour une période
bien déterminée afin de réduire le
risque de contamination par le virus de
son côté face au nombre croissant de
contagion en milieu scolaire le
ministère de l'éducation annoncé la
fermeture de 122 établissements
d'enseignement secondaire et 373 classe
sans pour autant confirmer la fermeture
temporaire de toutes les écoles depuis
la rentrée de janvier près de 7400
contamination au kobus 19 ont été
enregistrés sur l'ensemble des
établissements scolaires du territoire
tunisien
et dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale le désespoir de la
communauté palestinienne à jérusalem-est
dernière illustration en date ce lundi
une famille retranché sur le toit de sa
maison avec un baril d'essence depuis ce
matin un nouveau drame de l'expulsion
dans le quartier très sensible de cheikh
jarrah
yamina benguigui da
la colère et la détresse c'est ce qui
caractérise cette famille palestinienne
actuellement sur le point de se faire
expulser par des policiers israéliens
dans le quartier de cheikh djarrah
mohamed salia et des membres de sa
famille se sont retranchés sur le toit
de leur habitation avec un baril
d'essence un geste désespéré après que
les forces de l'ordre lui ai demandé de
quitter son domicile
je ne quitterai pas ma maison soit je
meurs dans ma maison soit givi si nous
partons où irons nous n'avons plus peur
ils ont déplacé nos familles dame carême
en 1948 et les ont fait fuir mais
aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus peur de
leur côté la police israélienne et la
mairie de jérusalem rappelle que le
terrain sur lequel se trouve la maison
est destiné à la construction d'une
école un leurre pour moi mais de salhiya
déterminés à ne pas quitter sa maison
familiale nous avons été surpris
aujourd'hui par l'arrivée des forces
d'occupation il y à un procès au
tribunal le 23 de ce mois mais ils n'ont
pas pu l'attendre et ont ordonné notre
expulsion si il y à un procès au
tribunal alors pourquoi nous expulse
eut-il ils ne prennent pas le procès en
considération mais au lieu de cela ils
veulent juste nous expulser de notaire
en utilisant l'excusent que c'est dans
l'intérêt public mais ce n'est pas vrai
ils veulent construire une nouvelle
colonie à cheikh jarrah et prendre le
contrôle des terres nous avons déjà été
déplacé de nos terres en 1948 et cela ne
se reproduira pas comme la famille salle
ya de nombreux palestiniens vivant dans
la partie orientale de jérusalem occupée
par israël sont confrontés à des ordres
d'expulsion en mai dernier des
manifestations de soutien à ces familles
menacées d'expulsion à cheikh jarrah
avait dégénéré en heurts avec des colons
et la police israéliennes s'en était
suivi des heures sévèrement réprimée
plus de trois cent mille palestiniens et
210 mille israéliens vivent aujourd'hui
à jérusalem est ces derniers dans des
colonies illégales au regard du droit
international
l'union européenne est très claire dans
un territoire occupé les expulsions sont
une violation du droit humanitaire
international
cela vaut pour toute expulsion ou
démolition y compris celles ci une
situation pourtant encouragé par la loi
indienne qui permet aux juifs pouvant
prouver que leur famille habitait dans
cette portion de la ville avant la
guerre de 1948 et la création d'israël
de demander à ce que leur soit rendu
leur droit de propriété
une loi qui n'a aucun équivalent pour
les palestiniens ayant perdu leurs biens
pendant la guerre et on s'intéresse à
présent au liban qui traverse vous le
savez la pire crise économique de son
histoire une délégation du fonds
monétaire international est arrivé
aujourd'hui à beyrouth une visite qui
prend la forme d'un dernier espoir pour
le pays du cèdre plongé dans une énorme
crise sociale politique et économique
le liban s'est déclarée en défaut de
paiement aux mars 2020 selon les nations
unies les trois quarts à delhi et en
sombrer dans la pauvreté pour en parler
nous sommes avec antoine sfeir avocats à
beyrouth et à paris maître de
conférences à l'université saint joseph
ainsi que claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales qui nous a
rejoint sur ce plateau bonsoir à tous
les deux merci d'être avec nous en train
de se faire que peut-on attendre du fmi
a fait des mois qu'on en parle c'était
vraiment la tente un petit peu ultime de
du liban s'est pour ainsi dire la
dernière chance selon vous
effectivement bonsoir un premier le le
problème se situe au niveau d'une crise
économique très dangereuse qui se passe
au liban spécialement appelé le las
l'évolution en guinée du 17 octobre 2019
jusqu'ici il n'y a pas de solution il ya
des problèmes au niveau des services
publics des services fondamentaux de la
justice de l'économie même bd des
éléments essentiels de la vie et on
attend toujours à cause des dissensions
entre les factions d'aidé des
gouvernements du pouvoir là les partis
qui gouverne le gouvernement de 2,1
diable qui fut formé après appelé la
révolution en 2019 il ya eu le défaut de
paiement en avril 2020 il y avait tous
ces problèmes les percussions et
jusqu'ici ce gouvernement n'a pas n'a
pas pu rien faire car il ya eu un
blocage qui a qui a duré à peu près deux
mois et on attend toujours de 1 si vous
voulez un ajustement sur le plan de de
de donner un coup de pouce si vous
voulez aux réformes voulues par le
peuple libanais en premier par le fmi
par la communauté internationale par les
amis du liban qui veulent qu'ils veulent
vraiment aider le liban afin de de faire
quelque chose pour le peuple libanais
qui souffre actuellement et c'est pas
c'est pas une question théorique c'est
une question pratique c'est une question
dangereuse et stratégiques c'est pour
cela on attend le fmi avec les les
cahiers de charges afin que le
gouvernement pourra adopter un budget
raisonnable
où l'utile c'est de donner un le
lancement à l'économie libanaise et
l'agréable en guinée c'est de donner au
peuple si vous voulez un espoir que les
problèmes au liban pour être tout à fait
résolus surtout rappeler les élections
parlementaires qui vont avoir lieu en
mai prochain alors le fmi à des cahiers
de charges en économie en dans les
affaires sociales en ce qui concerne
l'électricité la réforme du système du
secteur des télécoms et tout ça mais le
problème essentiel reste toujours qui a
dilapidé pour ne pas dire volé
l'argent du peuple libanais qui a volé
l'argent d'année montrent avant de
donner la parole à claude blanchemaison
va on va revenir vers vous dans quelques
instants au classement je fais on
rappelle que la monnaie a quand même
perdu 90% de sa valeur au liban les
trois quarts de la population basculer
dans la pauvreté la marge de manoeuvre
du fmi est ce qu'elle est tout de même
élevé parce que on part de très très
loin
le femi en effet est au chevet du liban
depuis le défaut de paiement et la crise
économique a été aussi aggravé par bien
sûr la crise sanitaire comme partout et
puis par l'explosion dans le port dans
le port de beyrouth au mois d'août 2020
explosion qui n'est toujours pas
véritablement élucidées est l'un des
problèmes alors le liban a quand même
fait des progrès au cours de ses
différentes missions puisqu'il a pu
faire chiffrer par l'administration
libanaise
l'importance des pertes environ 70 à 80
milliards de dollars dit-on et puis
le gouvernement libanais le gouverneur
de la banque centrale le célèbre
gouverneur qui est en place depuis 30
ans et qui a une banque qui n'est pas
très transparente et qui s'oppose à tout
à tout examen de deux de ses comptes eh
bien il est là il a estimé et c'est
probablement réaliste que pour relancer
la machine économique il fallait 15
milliards alors comme ça vient d'être
dit par monsieur serge eux je crois que
actuellement il se passe quelque chose
c'est à dire que les deux ministres
proches du hezbollah wii qui refusaient
de siéger dans le gouvernement depuis
trois mois pourrait revenir dans le
gouvernement parce qu'il semble que le
hezbollah élevés sont interdits c'est à
une vraie bonne nouvelle pour les
libraires depuis longtemps et c'est une
bonne nouvelle et le hezbollah
naturellement ne peut pas prendre une
décision de ce genre
et la transmettent par le biais du
président du parlement qui est assez
proche de cette tendance si
le feu vert n'avait pas été donné à
téhéran donc c'est très intéressant
parce que ça veut dire que quelque chose
a bougé et en effet l'iran n'a pas
intérêt à un effondrement total du liban
disparition du liban par conséquent
cette position a été assouplie et le
premier ministre qui n'avait pas pu
réunir son conseil des ministres
puisqu'il manquait deux ministres donc
mis les finances qui est très important
depuis trois mois a dit qu'il réunirait
le conseil des miss d'économiser
finances lui apporterait un projet
budget donc le budget dont on parlait
tout à l'heure devrait être élaborée
mais enfin ça peut peut-être pas être
élaborée en quelques heures il faut
peut-être un peu de temps et sur cette
base le conseil des ministres adoptera
un budget qui sera déjà quelque chose et
le problème restera en effet entier
c'est pas entre maintenant et les
élections qu'on va faire les réformes de
structure alors ça veut dire que les
réformes de structure ce sera peut-être
on peut toujours l'espérer pour après
encore que le système électoral est
telle que de toute façon au dernier au
résultat il faut respecter meva corps
qui est forcé d accord de partage de
pouvoir entre la présidence de la
république le premier ministre et le
président du parlement et que par
conséquent il ya peu de chances que la
classe politique change beaucoup après
fév élections même si il ya en effet des
mouvements dans la population pour
obtenir des changements alors dans le
fond ce qu'on attend de cette mission du
fmi c'est qu'elle donne un ballon
d'oxygène à ce gouvernement pour lui
permettre de passer le cap des élections
antoine sfeir tout à l'heure vous disiez
voilà on ne sait pas vraiment qui a
dilapidé mais enfin qu'est ce qui nous
garantit que cet argent qui va être
investi aujourd'hui pour soutenir le
liban et bien il va être mieux géré et
qu'on va réussir à a justement éviter
une forme de corruption dans ce pays
c'est ça le grand problème et c'est pour
cela la la conférence aids n'a pas pu y
voir le jour avec en exécution en
application vu qu'il y avait des
conditions alors après un pari deux
palettes loi y avait pas de condition
s'était ouvert lors il ya déjà des
milliards de dollars qui se sont
écoulées sur le marché libanais alors il
ya pour y avait beaucoup d'argent mais
le problème c'est que cet argent
appartient
aux la destination de cet argent fut
l'économie l'électricité les secteurs
principaux les secteurs vitaux les
services sociaux et tout ça ça n'a pas
été le cas actuellement s'il ya de
l'argent qui va être aussi injecté dans
le système libanais de par la communauté
internationale par le fmi ou par toute
autre organisation ou un état ça ne veut
pas dire que l'assainissement économique
et sociale va revoir le jour demain
alors c'est un problème concernant une
princesse concernant la composition et
l'esprit dont le pouvoir politique au
liban dans toutes ces parties je ne fais
pas de distinction alors c'était et ça
l'est toujours du business politique du
gouvernent le pays il n'y a pas de
contrôle il ya des queues comme comme
monsieur a dit yahya 70 yao 90 milliards
ça ccc le voulait la faille en guinée
alors mais qui en est responsable et on
est responsable on peut pas avoir une
responsabilité sans responsable on peut
pas revoir delà de la corruption sortent
sans qu'on l'on pût et corrupteur c'est
le problème c'est que les élections
parlementaires en mai prochain vont
constituer un début de changement alors
c'est trop dire si vous dire on dit que
le peuple libanais est réservé à
affaires traitées les habilités
actuellement à faire un grand choix afin
de faire un grand changement et vous
savez tous que le problème est monsieur
a bien à bien a bien insisté le problème
c'est aussi il a une portée régionale
internationale qu'on peut pas nier ça il
ya des partis politiques au liban
guillon des alliances avec d'autres et à
d'autres axes et c'est pour cela on est
toujours dense où la reine deviennent
alors on allait les réseaux sociaux même
les journaux liban est tout à leur
disque si à vienne où vas voir tu es un
commencement de rapprochement ou de
corps ou de d'accord alors ça va être si
vous voulez appliquer partiellement sur
la scène libanaise
alors ça c'est un pro il ya une portée
internationale
côté local on a bien en tout cas compris
des maisons de jeu et les difficultés
merci beaucoup antoine sfeir d'avoir été
avec nous au club blanche raison vous
restez avec nous parce que on va aborder
un tout autre sujet d'actualité puisque
des personnalités européennes défendre
la création drapeau euros nationale une
proposition faite dans une tribune au
jdd de quoi aviver les débats deux
semaines après la polémique liée au
remplacement du drapeau français par le
drapeau européen sous l'arc de triomphe
les explications en images avec juliette
l'a mis
dans cette tribune mise en ligne le 15
janvier dernier ils sont trois coauteurs
et une quarantaine de co signataires à
défendre l'identité européenne à travers
conception d'un nouveau drapeau afin de
signifier la double appartenance de
chacune et de chacun des citoyens
d'europe à leur nation et à l'union
européenne
on pourrait imaginer que chacun des
états membres puissent s'approprier un
nouveau modèle de drapeaux le drapeau
national
les auteurs de la tribune imagine un
drapeau telle une pièce d'un euro avec
la représentation de l'état membre sur
une face et celle de l'union européenne
sur l'autre ce nouveau drapeau ne
prendrait pas la place de l'étendard
national ou européen mais serait hissé
sur les édifices européen des pays
membres ou lors d'événements en lien
avec l'union européenne
nous sommes prêts a martelé que notre
destinée passe par l'union la seule voie
permettant d'éviter aux européens de
s'isoler du reste du monde ou deux
seulement en dépendre et de compter au
sein de celui ci
rédigé par trois français le texte a été
signé par des personnes physiques venant
de plusieurs pays européens notamment
des français et des italiens
une personne morale figurent parmi les
signataires
l'institut du commerce extérieur des
états unis
les auteurs de la tribune invite tous
ceux qui le souhaitent à hisser ce
nouveau drapeau le 9 mai prochain à
strasbourg à l'occasion de la fête de
l'europe claude blanchemaison vous
m'avez confié tout à l'heure ça m'a
presque fait sourire quand j'ai vu cette
information quelques est ce que ça dit
quelle est votre réaction j'ai en effet
cru que c'était une blague et oui mais
ça n'est pas du tout une blague puisque
des gens très sérieux des avocats des
magistrats des professeurs d'université
long sig et ils sont une petite
cinquantaine y en a quatre ou cinq qui
sont assez connus il n'ya pas d'un peul
il n'y a pas de personnages politiques
qui est appuyée 7,7 cette motion alors
l'exposé des motifs c'est un exposé des
motifs classiques pour dire que la
construction européenne c'est très
important parce que les états membres
sont trop petits dans la concurrence
internationale aujourd'hui pourrait
glisser bon mais effectivement le
l'aboutissement c'est une une
proposition un petit peu surprenante qui
est cette proposition d'un drapeau qui
soit sur une face au drapeau européen et
sur l'autre face au drapeau national en
se référant d'ailleurs à la monnaie
puisque nos pièces
sur l'euro ont une face européenne et
une phase nationale sauf que la monnaie
est unique elle est en concurrence avec
aucune autre monnaie et que ces pièces
bifaciales circulent dans tous les états
membres moi j'ai dans ma poche j'ai
vérifié tout à l'heure une pièce de deux
euros avec une phase européenne et une
autre phase qui est grave parce que
c'est comme ça donc alors là il s'agit
d'inventer un nouveau drapeau qui
s'ajouteraient aux vingt-sept drapeaux
nationaux et aux drapeaux européens
d'ailleurs inventaire 1955 par le
conseil de l'europe donc bien avant le
marché commun bien avant l'union
européenne et ses
drapeaux ces drapeaux ses 27 drapeau
supplémentaires viendraient
orner la façade des bâtiments publics
je doute que en effet cette cette
proposition et beaucoup de succès et je
doute que le que le 9 mai prochain le
jour que à bruxelles les fonctionnaires
appellent la sainte schuman
je doute qu'ils aient beaucoup de gens
pour aller
manifester avec ce drapeau d'ailleurs à
cette époque là on aura d'autres soucis
en france puisque ce sera l'élection
présidentielle fictivement merci en tout
cas claude blanchemaison d'avoir été
avec nous restez avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons du logement
principal poste de dépense des français
qui a fait lourdement le pouvoir d'achat
on compte près de 4 millions de français
mais loger nous irons justement la
rencontre de l'un d'entre eux dans notre
rubrique qu'en pensent les fons
[Musique]
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres la corruption la profonde
criminalité des états unis et de leurs
alliés de l'otan
ce sa page de réputation qui a commencé
quasiment immédiatement après la
publication des irakiens warlocks
l'isolent de la société
new york times
le washington post the guardian
der spiegel hugo
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment 1 je dirais
déçu oui mais pas surpris
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
quand
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
olivier maintenant détenu depuis huit
mois quelles sont les nouvelles les
nouvelles y en a très peu
malheureusement elles sont coupés de
tout il n'est pas dans un hôtel capturé
avec un téléphone et il peut nous donner
des nouvelles non à votre avis quelles
sont ses conditions de détention
aujourd'hui c'est sûr elles sont très
difficiles parce que les anciens otages
ont qu une
nous le racontait qu'il a des conditions
de vie qui sont très rudimentaires et
très dur j'espère vraiment de tout mon
coeur qui qui reçoit notre énergie moi
j'essaye de faire de mon mieux ils ont
tout simplement pour qu'ils m'entendent
parce que c'est ça mon travail c'est la
france et le mali où la france ou le
mali qui vont libérer olivier g pas ce
pouvoir de libérer mais par contre j'ai
le devoir d'une mobilisation je ne
l'abandonnerai part je ne laisserai pas
y'a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la table
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
sommes une force quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent ces gens qui
avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas d'oubli
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
le volontarisme politique atteint ses
limites pour les français sont de plus
en plus sceptique
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire la campagne présidentielle qui
arrive à grande vitesse et cette
question pourquoi les candidats parlent
aussi peu de logements et surtout du
même logement pourtant on compte près de
4 millions de mal logés en france nous
irons justement la rencontre de l'un
d'entre eux dans notre rubrique qu'en
pensent les français témoignage poignant
d'olivier qui vit un enfer depuis
maintenant trois ans gravement malade
handicapé il vit dans un logement
insalubre près de nantes et pousse un
cri de colère et un appel au secours
[Musique]
le logement est donc le principal poste
de dépense des français affectent
lourdement de pouvoir d'achat un thème
qui n'est curieusement toujours pas au
centre des débats politiques à moins de
trois mois de la présidentielle il y a
de quoi dire pourtant avec quatre
millions de mal-logés ce soir nous
donnons la parole à l'un d'entre eux
notre rubrique qu'en pensent les
français nous allons à la rencontre
d'olivier bellion prenantes
quinquagénaire via un véritable calvaire
depuis maintenant plus de trois ans il
se trouve dans un logement social un
salut ben alors qu'il est malade et
handicapée faute de moyens il ne peut
pas déménager et appels à l'aide les
politiques un reportage signé nadège à
dera sach et sébastien dufour
nous sommes à la chapelle glain en loire
atlantique pour y rencontrer olivier
bellion il fait partie des 20 millions
de français concernés par la pauvreté et
des 4 millions de mal logés
bonjour merci nous accueillir chez vous
rien olivier depuis plus de trois ans
vous habiter ici alors vous êtes
gravement malade et vous habiter dans un
logement insalubre
dans quelles conditions vous vivez au
quotidien c'est très désagréable vu mon
état d'avoir des remontées comme ça des
goûts et d'excréments et en fait je paye
un loyer de plus de 500 euros pour vivre
les pieds dans la merde quoi tout le
temps même l'hiver obligé d'ouvrir les
fenêtres tellement ça sent mauvais il
fait froid j'ai un poil derrière vous à
gad c'est trois bouteilles de gaz par
semaine à 40 euros la bouteille plus les
bougies nous enfin si vous comptez tout
c'est un budget qui me coûte à peu près
c'est cher que le loyer quoi ces 400 450
euros entre les bougies le gaz et les
autres produits pour les odeurs quoi est
ce que je peux dire excusez moi du terme
que vous vivez dans des grandes toiles
est votre maison sont des toilettes je
compare plutôt ma maison une fosse
septique en fait je vide je paye un
loyer depuis 2 500 euros pour pourvus
pour vivre dans une fosse septique
depuis bientôt quatre ans
et donc ils ont mis des fumigènes comme
je vous ai tout à l'heure et c'est comme
ça partout
bas derrière les tuyaux là c'est pareil
les fumigènes et la fumée a remonté qui
fait que même dans tous les lieux de la
cuisine crise ou pas la fumée à prince
qui m'expliquait par où passait
fumigènes passe les mauvaises odeurs
donc partout dans la maison et des
mauvaises odeurs qui remonte partout à
du fmi et allait pas trop le balzac au
mérite
en plus ces matches nuls les y contraint
on fait des excréments qui remonte par
ici cc plein et ça déborde il y en a
partout ça va jusque dans couloir voyez
comme poussé s'ouvrir tout le temps tout
en gris obligé c'est obligé là je ferme
tout méfait pour passer dans une r gt1
les bougies vous tenez pas dans la
maison ont vu voyez comment
malheureusement je suis malade 1 quand
vous vous levez à 2 heures du matin et
tout pour nettoyer tout ça croyez moi
que c'est pas grave vous recevez votre
enfant dans ces conditions ben moi
maintenant parce que j'ai pas envie
qu'il soit malade surtout que c'était là
qu'est la
mondiale et des gaz qui était dangereux
qui était même très dangereux pour la
santé
olivier c'est quand même assez
incroyable assez insensé que vous vous
sentiez plus à l'aise dehors en plein
mois de décembre à moins 20 degrés avec
votre bouteille d'oxygène dans votre
jardin que vous soyez mieux à
l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur va tout à
fait c'est meilleur pour moi ça sera sa
samba ça sent pas les excréments ni ni
la mère d'un pur pour être clair vous
savez même pas la visite de vos enfants
quoi dans ces circonstances là du tout
non non non non non non je sois pas
grand monde à part l'infirmière est ce
que vous regrettez
d'avoir emménagé dans cette maison il ya
quatre ans que oui et j'ai pas les
moyens de passer par une agence
immobilière ou par des particuliers
quand vous êtes reconnu e adultes
handicapés avec à peine 900 euros par
mois une fois que vous payez votre loyer
à 500 balles et vous asseyez des bougies
du 17 il vous reste pas grand chose
qu'on est à dire mais ouais mais j'ai
même écrit
madame sophie kluzek et ministre des
gens handicapés jamais une réponse
notre ancien premier ministre monsieur
edouard philippe
jamais eu de réponse ont vu jeudi au
pack lien intéressant de toute façon et
puis le par rapport à ta son on existe
pas ou peu si vous aviez un mot à dire
aux candidats à l'élection
présidentielle ce serait lequel
ces gens là premièrement je pense qu'ils
voient déjà le fauteuil la place et le
pouvoir donc tous tous pareil pour moi
ça donne pas envie d'aller voter en fait
que vous allez voter pour quelqu'un en
ayant certaines convictions et certaines
idées et une fois qu'ils sont passés ils
font rien ça m'étonne pas qu'ils aient
autant de gens qui ont pu voter il
occupa des gens voilà beaucoup
d'amertume on le comprend olivier est un
français qui se sont mis de côté par les
politiques alors une question se pose ce
soir pourquoi le logement n'intéresse
pas les candidats à la présidentielle
c'est l'objet de notre face à face et on
attend toujours vos réactions sur le
conte télégramme verte et france et le
dossier de notre émission
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler vincent
chauvet maire modem doter un bon soir
vincent chauvet merci d'être avec nous
en direct parce qu'à être sur ce plateau
philippe bourrier achi conseiller
régional écologiste merci aussi à vous
d'être là une réaction d'abord à ce
témoignage assainissent y en a qu'on
vient d'entendre une phrase importante à
la fin de ce reportage prononcé par
olivier ça ne m'étonne pas qu'il y ait
autant de gens qui ne vont plus voter
ils ne s'occupent pas des gens vous
comprenez cette colère vincent chauvet
oui après il reste peut-être à la
mauvaise personne c'est clairement de la
responsabilité de son maire le logement
insalubre d'ailleurs cette majorité a
voté une réforme de la police du
logement parce qu'il y en avait
plusieurs contradictoires c'était assez
compliqué moi dans ma commune j'ai mené
une petite très volontariste de lutte
contre le logement insalubre avec la
police municipale c'est un délit pénal
pour son propriétaire si c'est un office
hlm c'est encore pire et donc c'est au
maire de faire respecter la décence et
l'insalubrité il peut aussi écrire au
préfet qui se substitue au maire en cas
d'inaction mais clairement je connais
pas bien le dossier je découvre avec
vous ce soir mais ce type de situation
ne peut pas exister il y à une
réglementation qui est très claire et
des délits qui sont prévues les
tribunaux poursuivre extrêmement
lourdement les personnes qui laissent
des locataires dans cet état-là ensuite
s'il est lui même propriétaire
on a une question là d'assainissement
visiblement qui dysfonctionne et de la
même manière l'assainissement est une
compétence municipales ou
intercommunales
il y a des élus pas au niveau du
président de la république mais des élus
locaux qui doivent être là pour
l'accompagner et le faire sortir de
cette situation qui est parfaitement à
tolérer sauf qu'il y à plus de 4
millions de mal logés dans ce pays donc
ça va peut-être au delà d'une question
de relation avec un bailleur certes
peut-être pas correct mais on va éviter
de en faire la cible ce soir puisque on
ne lui a pas donné la parole ce soir on
le fera certainement dans les prochains
temps philippe bourgeat chi au delà
voilà de ce cas particulier qui a eu lui
pour 100 millions pardon de france est
mal logés ça vous évoque quoi une
inaction et des autorités vous l'avez
dit le rapport de la fondation de l'abbé
pierre est édifiant 4 millions de
personnes mal logées son logement on se
retrouve dans une situation un goulot
d'étranglement d'une politique de
l'habitat qui a été abandonnée alors
j'entends bien effectivement sur
certains points il y va de la
responsabilité des collectivités locales
des municipalités d'intervenir sur le
logement insalubre en mai faut-il encore
qu'il puisse y avoir des solutions b
parce que c'est le cas par exemple dans
votre commune vous est confiée il ya des
logements
vraiment inadmissible inhumaines des
marchands de sommeil mais vous savez
cette situation est dramatique et il a
dit quelque chose de très fort tout à
l'heure avec le peu de revenus qu'il a
il ne peut aller nulle part tout le
monde le refusera y compris dans des
offices hlm qui sont saturés et est dans
une situation catastrophique au niveau
du logement mais on pourra reparler des
des solutions mais ce qui se passe aussi
ce qu'on oublie souvent dans la
politique du logement c'est
qu'aujourd'hui 35 % des foyers seront
occupés par des personnes isolées ce qui
crée aussi la pénurie de logements mais
les solutions alternatives elles
existent elles existent dans le sens où
il faut bien évidemment
réquisitionné ces fameux million de
mètres carrés de bureaux vides qu'on
peut aménager et tout de suite
rapidement en logement digne décent il
faut que les mairies que les
municipalités soient impliqués et
applique la loi sru qui prévoit entre 20
et 25% selon la densité où vous vous
trouvez et aujourd'hui vous avez des
mairies qui préfèrent payer une amende
plutôt que d'avoir du logement social et
lorsqu'on fait du logement social c'est
plutôt pour des grandes familles et on
oublie souvent les personnes qui sont
seules et isolées
vincent chevet qu'est ce que vous
répondez
aux arguments que viennent de nous dire
philippe bourrier chine notamment les
solutions à cette critique de cette loi
effectivement qui date de 2000 ou qui va
d'ailleurs s'accentuer puisque en 2025
ça va aller jusqu'à 25 % de logements
sociaux et qu'on n'arrive pas toujours
finalement à faire respecter dans les
communes
et bien votre interlocuteur parle d'une
réalité qui existe certes qui est la
sienne et qui est assez spécifique
finalement à certaines régions qu on dit
tendu en termes de logements comme l'île
de france certaines grandes métropoles
votre sujet se passait à la chapelle
glas en plein milieu de la loire
atlantique et la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui un département sur deux
perd des habitants et que dans beaucoup
de petites villes je peux vous citer la
mienne on a 30 % de logements sociaux
vides vides et aujourd'hui d'un
politique du logement dans des villes
comme autant c'est de détruire des
logements vides pour justement recréer
des quartiers plus agréable et aussi
parce que ils sont vides depuis
plusieurs années qu'ils se dégradent à
ne pas être habité alors avant de
réquisitionner et d'utiliser des moyens
de coercition
vis-à-vis de
d'ailleurs de logements qui n'en sont
pas il est il est possible d'avoir une
autre politique d'aménagement du
territoire et faire en sorte que et bien
dans les endroits où on a des
concentrations très forte par exemple
d'administration ou autre et bien 2d
metropolis et c'est ce que d'ailleurs ce
gouvernement fait aussi autant va
accueillir par exemple à services
entiers des finances publiques de bercy
qui va qui va du coup être être
localisés dans notre ville mais
clairement c'est pas la même réalité
partout il ya 4 millions de mal logés
mais mal logés ça veut dire aussi en
surpopulation
ça veut dire aussi logés dans des
passoires thermiques et là on est
clairement dans un cac ait pas de mal
logement qui est dans un cas
d'illégalité manifeste ou une situation
comme ça ne peut pas perdurer après il
pourra travailler effectivement sur ces
quatre millions de personnes qui
habitent et bien à beaucoup dans peu
mètres carrés ou qui ont des factures et
qui augmente encore parce que les
logements ne sont pas ou mal isolés
c'est là la vraie problématique mais il
faut pas prendre le prisme du logement
sur paris ou la région parisienne où il
est impossible de se loger et aussi
d'autres réalités et il est il est
urgent de revoir justement au profit de
ces petites villes et d'arrêter de
concentrer dans les métropoles et
d'entasser finalement des gens dans des
quartiers dans des grandes alors c'est
vrai que ce sujet du logement pour
l'instant il n'a pas vraiment émerger un
dents dans cette campagne présidentielle
qui a malgré tout commencé avant nous
faire réagir on a posé cette question
alors pourquoi le logement n'intéresse
pas forcément les candidats sur le conte
télégramme dernier france on a eu cette
réaction elles sont tout simplement
complètement déconnecté de la réalité de
la vie des français beaucoup de
politiques ont des logements de fonction
tous frais payés par les contribuables
philippe bourion achi d'accord avec
cette téléspectatrice qui nous dit voilà
ils sont un petit peu hors sol est
déconnecté de la réalité ces polluants
en réalité très peu de politiques ont
des logements de fonction il faut que
vous ayez une fonction qui va avec donc
vraiment hormis les ministres qui sont
d'astreinte
non mais un logement de fonction c'est
qu'il ya une fonction qui va avec mais
vous avez raison sur le fait que c'est
une situation explosive il l'a dit les
français sont énormément déçu d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça qu'il ya un taux
d'abstention record et de promesses en
promesses c'est un sujet vraiment
explosif et un terrain glissant je
voudrais dire à monsieur le maire qui a
raison sur le fond sur la fameuse
décentralisation qu'on ne voit toujours
pas arrivés au moins vous m'avez dit que
ce gouvernement
va mettre vers chez vous un inspecteur
du ministère des finances mais c'est pas
un secteur qu'il en faudrait je crois
que c'est toute la france qu'il faudrait
décentralisée et qu'elle soit dotée à
parts égales de service public de
transport en commun et et je crois que
ce gouvernement a été réellement
défaillant là dessus et surtout là où ce
gouvernement a été défaillant ou là où
j'en suis sûr que les ninjas d'eau aura
une compétence réelle c'est celle vous
ne pouvez pas régler ce problème juste
sous le prisme il de l'état vous êtes
obligé que vous vouliez ou non de faire
une table ronde avec la région le
département l'intercommunauté de
communes le territoire de tout ce fameux
millefeuille qui vient s'entasser si
vous ne mettez pas tous ces acteurs
autour de la table y compris les
associations et y compris les bailleurs
sociaux eh ben ça ne fonctionne pas
parce que chacun va tirer la couverture
vers soi sur son territoire à buoux pas
électoraliste mais si vous mettez pas
tous ses acteurs y compris des
associations qui s'occupent vers les
gens qui sont en plus en difficulté les
amicales de locataires les citoyens et
ben ça ne peut pas fonctionner et donc
au lieu de fermer la porte et désire que
jupiter et le tout puissant il faut
qu'ils apprennent à composer avec les
corps intermédiaires ce qui lui a fait
défaut jusqu'à présent vincent chauffer
votre réponse à lui a fait défaut
emmanuel macron quel est son bilan en
matière justement de logements alors il
ya eu des avancées il ya eu aussi des
loupés on se souvient notamment de la
réforme des apl où on avait retiré 5
euros personne n'avait rien compris et
finalement on était revenu dessus bon la
réalité c'est quand même que ce système
des appels dysfonctionne ça coûte des
milliards d'euros et si ça marchait on
n'aurait pas effectivement c'est 4
millions de mal-logés donc je pense
qu'il faudra une réforme d'ensemble où
les apn dont certains dans certains
départements dans certaines régions donc
fait que tirer les loyers vers le haut
en soldes mobilisant des personnes est
en fait en engraissant finalement des
propriétaires dont on sait d'ailleurs
que ce sont souvent des gens qui
concentre déjà beaucoup de patrimoine
donc là c'est très clair en revanche je
donnerais par exemple à mon
interlocuteur la loi qui vient d'être
votée de décentralisation des lois 3d
3ds où on fait des intercommunalités les
autorités organisatrices du logement qui
vont pouvoir gérer certaines aides qui
vont pouvoir avec la mise en place de
plans locaux d'urbanisme intercommunaux
gérer ce qu'on appelle la politique de
peuplement c'est à dire simplement
d'arrêter d'entasser toutes les
personnes dans les mêmes quartiers de
faire en sorte qu'on construise dans les
dents creuses et qu'on fasse pas
d'étalement urbain est aussi une grosse
polémique quand la mise du logement
emmanuelle wargon a dit et il faut
arrêter la maison individuelle en
lotissement qui est un peu le rêve des
français mais aujourd'hui d'un point de
vue écologique d'un point de vue social
il faut reconstruire la ville sur la
ville et à ce titre le plan action coeur
de ville et la densification des
centre-villes retrouver des habitants
centre-ville vous savez par exemple dans
nos petites villes il ya beaucoup de
boutiques vides souvent aussi avec des
logements vides au dessus qui était
anciennement les logements des artisans
et bien la politique est très compliqué
effectivement il faut travailler en
partenariat et ça c'est une vraie
réussite du gouvernement et bien a
permis de sur le logement des délits d
sur le marché des logements enfin j'en
profite pour dire à votre interlocutrice
qui effectivement quasiment aucun est
l'une de logements de fonction peut-être
certains ministres à paris qui
n'habitent pas à paris en ont et
d'ailleurs si on avait des logements de
fonction j'aurais pas mon chat qui
essayent de perturber ce skype depuis
tout à l'heure
c'était plus simple pour vous répondre
bienvenue au chat film pur gâchis c'est
vrai qu'ils mèneront c'était un petit
peu distingué dans le gouvernement d
emmanuel macron en disant voilà il faut
oublier cette aberration de la maison
individuelle alors c'est vrai qu'on
dépasse un petit peu de l'aspect du mal
logement qui est l'objet de ce débat
mais ça vous avez inspiré quoi vous en
tant qu'écologiste écouter lorsqu'on
refuse l'artificialisation des sols nous
on peut que se réjouir de cette
situation mais il faut juste expliquer
pourquoi les gens choisissent la maison
individuelle ils veulent aussi et on l'a
vu pendant cette période de pandémie les
parisiens sont devenus fous il n'avait
pas d'espacé il ne voulait ou ne pouvait
pas respirer ne pouvait pas sortir je
parle du premier confinement qui a rendu
mais complètement hystériques les gens
et puis vous avez malheureusement des
fois pas le d'autre alternative que de
vous reculez
ddd points centraux des centres villes
pour pouvoir vous logez parce que c'est
inabordable et la vraie situation là
dessus moi je me rappelle que ce
gouvernement avait promis enfin ce jeu
présent la république avait promis
qu'ils auraient zéro sdf qu'il en ferait
une priorité il a été défaillant de
boutons ou et effectivement cette voie
de 3d on pourrait se dire qu'elle va
dans le bon sens un gevrey je ne jette
pas toujours le bébé avec l'eau du bain
mais c'est quand même étrange qu'elle
arrive aussi tardivement pour pour un
grand réformateur que et notre président
la république ce jeune quadra qui irait
mans avait des relents de giscard n'est
pas que dans l'apparence mais aussi dans
les actes le truc il est bien clair si
si vous ne permettez pas aux gens de
pouvoir se loger dignement si vous ne
pouvez pas maîtriser les prix des loyers
il faut juste se rendre compte une chose
très simple c'est que le tour 9 heures
sur le logement social ces cinq cent
mille par an dans le logement privé
c'est un million cinq si vous ne
permettez pas aux propriétaires de ces
logements privés d'avoir un fou garantie
contre les loyers impayés et bien vous
allez vous avez faire en sorte de faire
la réunification du bien et du produit
et quand tout à l'heure j'ai entendu que
c'était pas des logements les bureaux
qu'on pourrait transformer en fin de
compte vous garder que les murs externes
les plateaux et puis à l'intérieur c'est
du volume que vous pouvez aménager comme
vous voulez et on voit bien qu'avec le
télétravail d'ailleurs groupama avait
dit il ya un an que plus de 30 à 40% de
ses locaux vont rester vacants et c'est
là où on peut essayer de transformer
pour éviter la ratification des salles
et tout en faisant permettant
l'encadrement des loyers et des prix web
à la fin du débat je voudrais vous faire
réagir rapidement messieurs sur ce
chiffre on l'a dit ça représente une
dépense principale
des foyers français en ces temps le
pouvoir d'achat justement est la
préoccupation principale part du revenu
consacré donc par les ménages au
logement 20% 2021 contre 16% en 2001
sans chauve et café emmanuel macron pour
remédier à cette situation sachant
justement que les choses empirent comme
on le voit sur ce chiffre
effectivement le moi je pense pas que
l'encadrement des loyers soit sur la
bonne solution encore une fois il faut
pas voir avec le prisme parisien votre
reportage tout à l'heure si tu es un
loyer de 500 euros pour une maison
individuelle
à paris ça paraît délirant mais c'est la
réalité et 500 euros même si on vit
finalement avec avec un smic alors si on
vit au rsa c'est très compliqué mais là
il ya du logement social mais cinq cents
500 euros pour une famille ça peut être
ça peut être un loyer qui est tout à
fait abordable et aujourd'hui beaucoup
de centre-ville je leur dise beaucoup de
centre-ville sont tout à fait abordable
il faut pas généraliser la situation
parisienne ensuite il reste évidemment
beaucoup de choses à faire sur sur le
logement la principale action ça a été
et c'est important et probablement dans
votre chiffre de 20% il ya une part
d'énergie c'est là m'a pris 9dans france
rennes-om un grand plan financier
d'ailleurs avec le plan de relance
européen en partie un grand plan
écologique d'isolation et dead de
subventions directes aux français pour
que leur logement leur coûte finalement
pas plus cher en gaz et en électricité
quant aux loyers ça il faudra le
poursuivre parce qu'on va pas assez vite
et c'est clairement un gain de pouvoir
d'achat pour les français qui ont pu en
bénéficier qui pourront continuer en
bénéficier le mot de la fin pour vous
moi je suis satisfait que la macro ni
prennent les idées des écologistes et
les propositions gaver faire yannick
jadot depuis les européennes de 2019
mais vous allez on nous on est pour les
logiciels libres il n'y a pas de
copyright mais s'ils ne savaient pas
faire voter yannick jadot nous on sera
très bien le faire je voudrais juste
rajouter une chose vous avez raison
lorsqu'on est excentré ben ça coûte un
peu moins cher sauf que vous avez
obligatoirement pratiquement
obligatoirement besoin de votre véhicule
parce que la désertification des
transports publics que vous avez
accentuée pour privilégier les grandes
lignes enfin deux les lignes à grande
vitesse sont que les français lorsqu'ils
se loge - sont obligés de dépenser plus
pour leur transport donc on saura y
remédier et faites nous confiance encore
beaucoup de pain sur la planche merci à
tous les deux fini borias fille sur ce
plateau vincent chauvet et c'est la fin
de cette omission merci de l'avoir suivi
rendez-vous donc à partir de demain 20
heures d'ici là n'oubliez pas de régie
vient de commenter poster vos questions
sur le télégramme d'ayrté france merci à
vous et l'actualité continue toute la
soirée en direct
[Musique]
olivier maintenant détenu depuis huit
mois quelles sont les nouvelles les
nouvelles y en a très peu
malheureusement elles sont coupés de
tout il n'est pas dans un hôtel capturé
avec un téléphone et il peut me donner
des nouvelles non à votre avis quelles
sont ses conditions de détention
aujourd'hui c'est sûr elles sont très
difficiles parce que les anciens otages
aucune
il racontait qu'il a des conditions de
vie